a question that everyone is asking
what's it like today PewDiePie
today is your lucky day because that's
what we're gonna find out here today
date PewDiePie simulator it's a game
made by Malcolm 1466 and his girlfriend
Jessica the name sounds familiar
where have I heard that name before
anyway let's play it okay so we will get
points for how we answer tally your
score at the end to see how well your
you are date with Felix Kjellberg goes
alright here we go
where do you take him water zoo Great
Wall of China Nickelback concert VidCon
come on we need a hundred points which
one is it Ireland 100 points cuz you can
visit a real man like jacksepticeye's I
already hate this quest what you are
wearing for him something light and
frilly Hatsune Miku cosplay a Swedish
flag tracksuit is that a thing because I
need that right now yeah buy ten of them
anyway I see a lot of fans wearing hats
any Miku cosplay so I'm gonna go with
Hatsune Miku cosplay zero points Felix
is racist what god dammit this doesn't
prove anything
how many points do we have 100 points we
have hundred points what you are ordered
food for Felix to eat what the [ __ ] is
this a sentence can you [ __ ] learn
proper English we will eat IKEA
meatballs I don't even have to read the
rest 5 points to dis guesting but he
will like it now listen here how [ __ ]
dare you what music you will pay for
Felix in the car
so Evanescence evanesce says ok we will
go with evern SSNs say hi pods cuz he
needs to wake up and kill himself why
are you so mean
ok well I'll take my five points hundred
and ten thank you very much
what will you do to him at your home
nothing hold hands and prayer kiss him
six him sex him hard sex him hard
five points this kid how [ __ ] dare
you sex him [ __ ] would cry and not
become a ranked Wow what about after the
sex call him a cab send that [ __ ] home
what if [ __ ] that picture of Bella
that's really cool
ask his number from him let him stay
over the night sex him again slaughter
him and his entire bloodline 50 points
what the [ __ ] is that
you calling me a race but if you have
the chance no matter the risk
you must attempt to kill this [ __ ]
dead forever he is cancer okay maybe
maybe we should ask his number from him
five points screenshot his text for key
I mean that seems possible 120 points
get team on the DMS why you probably got
some nice juicy [ __ ] to try and ruin
Felix life with great job but could have
been you are the chosen one the dark Sun
rising again to save us all from the
AIDS that is PewDiePie channel I have
freed your mind but I can only show you
the door
you're the one who must walk through it
what if the quest was made by a Malcolm
1466 congratulations disciples we have
completed phase two and he has no idea I
mean you just told me Dylan has
distracted him belonging at what the
[ __ ] soon we will strike
Phase three the killing blow no homo
it's Jessica and Jessica has returned
you will obey my command food impe needs
to be destroyed
say after me Pulido EP sucks so it good
phase two complete
I will return when the time comes
Jessica out
that was the video leave a like if you
enjoyed and if you did leave a like and
also don't forget to leave a like if
this video hits more than 2 likes it's
funny cuz I'll probably get like
hundreds and hundreds of thousands well
at least I didn't call out the likes in
the beginning of a video like a [ __ ]
asking for likes give me likes no need
more [ __ ] like and leave a like don't
forget to leave a like and subscribe and
leave a like thank you for liking
bro-bro like my name's I don't give a
[ __ ] get off my seat